okay so we do know that the finale is
now gonna be like information that just
came in hot off the presses oh yeah you
announce it well knowing what happens in
the 21st episode how our fans gonna feel
about that being the finale I think it's
still got some really great cliffhanger
things I quickly just peek because you
just told me what where we're gonna end
it cuz it just came in I mean look I
think the most important thing is you
know we all want to make sure that we
are flattening the curve and keeping
everyone safe so we have to end with
this episode because it was the ones
that we finish with but the writers are
so good that it's gonna totally work as
finale and I think again this
quintessential
Grey's you will be laughing and crying
simultaneously and then we've got a
whole bunch of amazing thing then in
store for you guys for the new season
what can you tease about this new finale
episode what sort of happens what
answers will we get in this episode you
definitely will get some answers and you
will definitely get some new kind of
questions of like oh my god what's gonna
happen there's definitely a couple I
quickly just while you were getting your
news from your producer I quickly just
looked at which which episode it was and
you know the last scene is sort of a
whoa what does that mean so it's kind of
kind of I think is gonna work out
perfect that that's I mean I'm sad that
we only have two more shows for you guys
but you know where everyone were I think
if they could I want to be able to have
more for you guys but it just means
we'll have more next season knowing
where this episode ends do you think the
writers will pivot we sort of talked
about this earlier or do you think you
guys will finish filming the rest of the
episodes as part of season 17 knowing
that this is the finale I mean that's a
really good question and again I you
know I trust krysta to figure out what
is best for the show you know it if
because
have more time to kind of you know maybe
they'll rework the scenes that they have
and include that maybe it'll pick up I
think that's a really kind of writer
question I think we have some amazing
stuff in the can and so I'm sure I'm not
sure but I would think that they would
use some of those great scenes that
we've already shot but I also equally
think that you know maybe that's their
thinking this is an opportunity to see
how things played out and what they want
to kind of raise you know higher stakes
or you know include and if it's it's an
opportunity to kind of rework the campus
well we get answers about Richard and
these final two episodes then I'm pretty
sure yes what's happening I don't know
okay and our fans gonna feel I don't
want to give any spoilers but I think
fans will be I think they should tune in
okay and will we get some sort of
resolution in these final two episodes
with the Owen Tom Teddy I think it's
juicy I think there's definitely
something you guys should not miss I
literally I like went under the table at
the table Rita like Oh what I mean there
is like such like a Quintus and I know I
keep saying this but there is such a I'm
gonna start blushing there is like just
you have to you guys have to watch okay
all right well our fans gonna be happier
with Teddy are they gonna continue being
a little bit frustrated by her it's
gonna give it away
that's gonna give it away I could their
I mean look teddy is really need some
help I love her
I love him more consumer not only was
she with this woman the woman ended up
dying in 9/11 it was also an affair were
you what was your reaction when you
first heard that this was gonna happen
it was like it was such like a surprise
for me I mean like we all like at the
table Reaver like it was and then it was
like of course it was sort of I thought
like another genius move on Christa and
the writers because it just makes total
sense you know and that's what's so
great about like episodic television and
I know that Teddy is making some in her
present life making some really really
not great choices but I thought I think
the facts also really interesting to
lean into and I think that you know
Christa and Shonda have always believed
that like the messiness is is where we
kind of learn and grow and and to not be
afraid of that so I feel like her
flashback with Alison was such an aha
moment you know and I was so lucky Matt
our guest actors Cherie
Andrea was just so amazing to work with
and they're both so talented and so I
think it was a and then like that of
course makes total sense do you think so
you think it's possible to be in love
with two people and that maybe she is
both in love with Tom and with Owen I do
I think you are able to love two people
I mean in very different ways right and
that's I think what Teddy is is
struggling with and I think it really
also comes down to Teddy's lack of
self-love you know she like her the
whole time on Grace she's really been
like if I look back at it and I'm you
know trying to figure out the mechanics
of Teddy and she's really always in a
way been with unavailable people and I
think that that's something that she
really needs to examine like if I'm
gonna like analyze Teddy
and I think that that's because she's
afraid to be loved and I think that that
is kind of in a way universal when we're
picking partners it first comes them not
to be so like philosophical but like it
does come down to like self love in
order to be loved and I think that's
such a beautiful thing to be looking and
I know the fans are super upset with
Teddy right now and I totally get it
and because these joy they're gonna mean
like I get it but I'm gonna lean into
that and so to try to like you know
Teddy's complicated she's messy and but
aren't we all aren't we all sort of
multi-layered and complicated I know we
all don't make like poor choices like
that but I think those poor choices I
hope will will lead Teddy to really
finding love you know and and love
that's like you know I'm look I think
the affair with Teddy and I know I'm
kind of going off on a tangent I think I
think that's because she's afraid
I think it's that she does love two
people but I also think that she's
afraid I think that she also needs to
figure out that she's worthy of love and
then she won't then be making these
crazy doing these kind of crazy
messed-up thing cheating like that's the
cheating messed-up thing right like I
think her love is pure for both of those
people and she really does love both of
those people it's the way she's going
about it that's really messed up I mean
that's exactly what I was gonna ask you
is about her decision-making process
because if you think about it it goes
way back to literally years ago like she
was engaging in this type of behavior so
might we learn a back story about why
she's sort of handling things this way
why she gets involved in these affair
love triangle situations kind of walking
me through I hope so I mean Kristen and
I were sort of talking about it you know
like what is what's the journey gonna be
I don't think it's gonna I don't think
it's gonna wrap up neatly like the
episodes they're coming up oh my gosh
like like you you thought like these
were aha moments last night I mean for
Thursday night whenever you guys are
this it's there's some curries
things coming up in the next two
episodes so I think like I think I'm
hoping and Kris and I are talking about
it that that we do walk Teddy into and
understand why she's doing what she's
doing and then also like through the
messiness get her to that better place
um so I think I think it's it's what's
really cool also is that it's not just
we're not gonna wrap it up and it's not
gonna be a neat little bow because I
don't think that that's life I think
it's gonna take it's it's gonna take
some messiness before she gets in
clarity I also do want to talk more
about the first responders because you
guys did donate masks and gowns and I
believe so how did that feel to know
that your show was able was able to do
that I'm it was a tremendous relief you
know we ou know a lot of the trauma
surgeons and a lot of the doctors who
come and help us on Grey's you know
during sort of before during kind of the
regular work time before all of this hit
and you know it was really it's really
scary to know that they can't protect
themselves if they don't have the right
equipment and I think all of us at home
want to make sure that we can help in
some way and so to know that Grey's
could donate those masks and those gowns
it's so moving to see how everyone is
trying to do their part in helping I
feel like you know again it's like a
time where everyone can use their
ingenuity to try to figure out how to
get us through this together yeah
absolutely
so going back to this episode I mean
Teddy named her daughter Allison which
further shows like how much that that
previous relationship impacted her how
do you think it really changed her like
was that the love of her life because
you said that Teddy was the love of
Allison's life I do think it it is one
of her loves of her life you know I mean
I think look I think we all have sort of
like a love of our life
that that is like a major influence on
how we proceed in our life in love and
and and all of that and but I think that
that's I think Allison yes is the love
of her life and I and I think teddy is
trying to figure out now is there room
to to find that again and I think she's
also dealing with a lot of like um other
issues you know it's like she survived
and Allison didn't she was the love of
her life and so there's a lot of things
that she you know and not having that
and and losing that person and maybe
never grieving that person and so I
think that teddy is is is trying to
figure out how to lead a kind of healthy
life and love life and it does it I
think it does start with Allison you
know and also teddy lost both of her
parents so there's been a lot of loss in
Teddy's life and I think so there's a
lot of fear in terms of letting people
into her life I think that's also a part
of why she's kind of behaving the way
she is behaving in present time and
making those kind of bad choices of you
know having these affairs I'm it's like
a continuous thing with Tom I think she
kind of she also goes back to Tom you
know for reasons that I'm not making
excuse me just some explanation because
she was afraid that when you know she
was afraid that Owen wasn't gonna pick
her again so they're not like rationally
kind of thought out things but I think
you know she does she's you know when
she lost Alison she's afraid of losing
that love of her life again so when I
guess I should say if Owen finds out
that she has cheated on him with Tom how
is he gonna react and how is it affect
the relationship
wait to the last was I mean any time to
think about that what was the last part
of the question
if and how Owen finds out that she
cheated on him with Tom how is he gonna
react and how will that affect you gotta
watch the next couple episodes a because
if we thought we fell off of our chairs
during the table read on 19 oh no it's
it's like really don't want to spoil
anything but it's it's great
does she have to choose between Tom and
Owen maybe does she need to choose
herself for a little bit kind of like a
funny
love triangle oh let me just say it it's
messy it's really messy but it's really
good I mean in a in a very Grey's
Anatomy way okay how's that for an
answer that was very helpful who do you
think is a better match for teddy Tom or
Owen I think they both are great matches
in different ways okay
see how I'm trying to get out of that
one nine out of three political you look
I think I think Owen and teddy have a
history that is just so deep that I'm
very attached to you know I mean they
literally went to war together
so that's really huge for me but then I
also I think that you know Teddy has an
understanding of Tom and like his deep
pain of having lost his son and there's
a really beautiful episode coming up and
understanding also more of Tom and I
think that that's really informative to
kind of understand who Tom is you know
underneath that kind of veneer that his
character is on the outside which I
think Teddy seeds so I think it's gonna
come down to can Teddy figure out that
she's worthy of being loved and then
who's that best match
gonna take you home you're not feeling
well I'm fine something also very tragic
happened last night with Richard I'm
sure you've seen on social media the
fans are going wild
was that a stroke was it something else
can you kind of walk us through what's
going on with yeah I mean that scene
when we fill in that scene with Richard
giving the speech I mean I literally was
getting like body chills because we God
we all love him so much can say that
Grey's Anatomy like the hospital and
every doctor comes together in in such a
fantastic way to sort of figure out and
problem-solve like what is the problem
and it's it's so terrific and it speaks
volumes for Jim's character that he's so
beloved so that is definitely like a big
chunk of the next couple episodes is he
going to be okay I don't think I'm
allowed to give away anything there's a
few other
I mean characters having like major
storylines right now anything in store
for Meredith people want to know are
they trying to put her together with
Mick Widow is there hope for he's so
great it was so beautiful to learn why
he's so hesitant to proceed in love and
because you see what he's been through
and I and I think that that is also so
human and it's so human that we don't
know why people act the way they act and
I think that there is also like a great
human trait for the way we treat people
and we don't know why people act the way
they do are we meant to think that
there's a future for him and Meredith or
are we meant to hold on to hope for
DeLuca and Meredith I think there's
another love triangle I don't know I
mean it's like very Grey's Anatomy it's
a love triangle yeah it is we got to
keep it complicated and juicy and cuz
yeah I think that that maybe that's the
that's the theme of this the season 16
[Music]